des boulettes vous avez forcément dû en
faire
ah oui en plus j'étais plutôt en direct
moi qui était enregistré tout le reste
était en direct j'ai fait alors
maintenant vous parler de ça j'ai fait
une bourde mais c'était très emmerdant à
l'époque il y avait Mylène Farmer et
Jeanne Mas qui était au top des charts
c'était vraiment c'était vraiment les
deux elle se disputer les premières
places vraiment évidemment elles étaient
rivales et pas du tout ami donc un jour
c'était le samedi après-midi dans la une
est à vous je présentais sur TF1 je
reçois Mylène Farmer mais tu es dans ces
cas-là tu penses à Jeanne Mas je ne sais
pas pourquoi parce que tu te dis il faut
surtout pas parler de Jeanne Mas tu sais
comment je démarre l'émission bonjour
c'est la lutte à vous je suis ravi de
vous accueillir Jeanne Mas aïe aïe
alors elle est mignonne elle a la souris
mais l'horreur moi c'est on a quelques
bourses qui sont très très drôle on va
commencer avec une énorme boulette d'un
candidat de tout le monde veut prendre
sa place qui s'est légèrement trompé
dans sa réponse alors
regardez la quand je vous dis tromper
c'est le grand écart regarde un texte
écrit en prison en 1930 qui affirme la
non-violence et mon premier article de
foi c'est aussi le dernier article de
mon credo Adolf Hitler
mais il est en prison en 1930 donc à peu
près la non violence est mon premier
article de foi Adolf Hitler j'ai pas
écouté la phrase en fait c'est loin
d'être le [ __ ] et le nazi qui est
Hitler c'est le génial Gandhi d'accord
non mais je me suis dit on est un peu à
déposer
Hitler c'est vraiment le grand écart
mais là aussi c'est le trouble sur moi
la télé ah oui mais bon moi j'en ai fait
une très belle sur Secret Story je
devais parler d'un coup de buzz et j'ai
parlé d'un coup le 3 points merci
beaucoup alors là c'est regardez bien
c'est une candidate de candidate du
maillon faible et la question est quelle
est la femelle quelle est la femelle du
lièvre
alors vous allez voir ce qui est
hallucinant c'est le temps la réflexion
avec la meuf elle mature bien sa réponse
elle est sûre d'elle et elle donne sa
réponse regarde
alors Sandra quelle est la femelle du
lièvre
la levrette
mauvaise réponse
[Applaudissements]
allez alors encore une autre boulette
cette fois elle concerne un président de
la République regardez
on s'appelle le jeune Macron
généralement consommé en marinade
Emmanuel
[Applaudissements]
Macron
ah c'est pas le même généralement
consommé en marinade
ça s'appelle la Lisette
c'est drôle
ça c'est mignon
on a les nôtres qui est incroyable
il y a encore qui va apprendre il y a
une question de Jean-Luc Reichmann et il
va apprendre en direct qu'en fait il est
cocu un peu comme vous gilbertez
le compliment
enfin la situation un peu cocasse vous
en faisant le SI jeudi il va me tuer et
puis j'ai proviseur du lycée qui va il
va peut-être me poursuivre du lycée on a
cassé le lavabo des toilettes
ça c'est horrible ça c'est horrible j'ai
appris aussi que j'étais quasiment en
direct ça fait mal
à la télé dans les journaux
c'est laquelle c'est une belle blonde
alors grosse gaffe vous avez fait des
cours alors vous vous êtes des grosses
gaffes
parce que un jour à la radio une immense
personnalité dont je dirais pas le nom
est morte j'avais pas vu que le micro
était encore ouvert et j'ai dit c'était
quand même une incroyable [ __ ]
c'est un classique en télé faut vraiment
se méfier vraiment Hugo non vous n'ont
pas de boulettes particulières aussi
quand même il y a quelques mois j'ai
quand même demandé à si euh
si ça l'intéressait de faire un one man
show alors qu'il était là pour faire la
promo pour spectacle
de chaleur quand même à ce moment-là en
fait
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez mon ABS
c'est vrai puis depuis maintenant il
s'est passé est-ce que vous avez une
absence parce que c'est vrai que le gars
pendant 10 minutes il parle pas c'est
facile de son spectacle et c'est vrai
que c'était une vanne et non c'était pas
une blague ça vous intrigue vous vous
demandez qu'est-ce qu'il y a bien passé
c'est mort de rire
avant première le Roi Lion c'est Rayane
bensetti qui prête sa voix à Simba et
une voix il me dit comment qu'est-ce que
tu as pensé j'ai trouvé c'était vraiment
génial de A à Z et surtout la chanson là
il a acquiescé sauf que c'était pas lui
qui chantait et c'était l'endroit le
moment où c'est la gare
parfait
gênant lorsque tu comptes de ça c'est
pas c'est pas ouf c'est pas ouf c'est
une histoire alors vous avez fait des
oui non moi je suis professionnel
vous avez jamais pris un mot pour un
autre ou euh bon en tout cas on va
terminer avec la dernière boulette
question pour un champion visiblement il
n'a pas du tout du tout du tout compris
la question regardez
monsieur oui ça va de Marseille
[Applaudissements]